les grands hôtels ne sont pas encore
pleins et les vedettes ne sont pas
arrivés mais tranquillement la ville
reine se prépare pour le type et après
deux ans en formule hybride le festival
fait son retour en présentiel et nolwenn
le pdg dutil s'en réjouit et confirme
que très peu d'événements seront tenus
en ligne
il n'y a pas que les salles de cinéma
qui reprendront vie après un hiatus
force et c'est aussi le retour des
grandes soirées du tiff un
incontournable du calendrier mon vin de
toronto ce soir on se prépare à
accueillir des invités qui se rendront à
la première soirée de la saison celle
qui ouvre le bal des célébrations à deux
semaines du début du festival ici aussi
on a laissé tomber le format hybride des
canapés et des cocktails pas de masques
ou de distanciation social
pour ce
n'est par l'hôtesse de la soirée natacha
kokmen organise cet événement chez elle
depuis une vingtaine d'années ce soir
elle reçoit presque 300 personnes
et ces soirées hollywoodiennes ne sont
pas qu'une excuse pour faire la fête
elle rassemble des investisseurs des
producteurs des acteurs des
entrepreneurs toutes sortes de personnes
qui sont venues brasser des affaires
une réalité que confirme ce producteur
de films qui confie avoir déjà conclu
des ententes lors de soirées comme celle
ci et ce ne sont pas que les invités qui
brassent des affaires en plus des
convives une cinquantaine de personnes
sont employées lors d'une soirée comme
celle-ci chaque cuisinier serveur barman
dj autant de métiers qui ont presque
disparu avec la pandémie et qui
reviennent en force cette année
il y à toute une industrie dernière une
soirée comme celle ci explique paolo
pusateri qui est propriétaire d'une
entreprise de traiteur à elle seule
cette soirée représente près de 10 mille
dollars pour l'homme d'affaires et les
deux semaines du type sont parmi les
plus occupés de la saison juste après
l'action de grâce
une saison occupé qui permettra de
renflouer les coffres après deux ans
d'accalmie car au delà du glamour et des
paillettes le tiff demeure un des
événements culturels les plus lucratifs
au pays avec des retombées économiques
de plus de 150 millions de dollars si à
ce média radio canada toronto